[Musique]
José Legault Émilie Nicolas Christian
Dufour bonsoir bonsoir je vais faire
tout de suite le tour de table sur les
élections américaines ont devant parlait
plus tard mais comme je viens d'en
parler je suis sur mon élan est-ce que
c'est important pour vous qu'est-ce que
vous surveillez parce que oui aux
États-Unis mais on se le cachera pas ce
qui se passe aux États-Unis à des
répercussions sur toute la planète et
entre autres au Canada José
ah ben oui c'est sûr
c'est non seulement c'est la plus grande
puissance mondiale mais c'est la porte à
côté
et on voit tout particulièrement depuis
la victoire de Donald Trump en 2016
avant sa défaite conjo binden que
l'influence du trumpisme et planétaire
presque là et incluant le Canada donc
oui c'est très très important Emilie
Nicolas important ce qui se joue est-ce
qu'on a exagéré Barack Obama je le
disais tout à l'heure a dit en fin de
semaine c'est la démocratie qui est en
jeu donc qu'on met la barre aussi haute
les temps sont durs
non mais je pense que bon on peut pas
savoir exactement ce que voulait dire
Barack Obama mais notamment des choses
que je lis dans ce qu'ils disent c'est
une allusion peut-être indirecte à ce
qui s'est passé au niveau des États dans
les dernières années où il y a plusieurs
étapes qui ont fait des réformes
électorales ou modifier les lois pour
essentiellement avantagé les
républicains dans l'urne de ce qui va se
passer ce soir donc une révision parfois
des cartes électorales une révision pour
rendre plus difficile le vote de
certains communautés qui sont bien sûr
connus pour voter plutôt du côté
démocrate donc il y a eu des efforts qui
ont été faits pour renverser ces lois là
mais ça peut passer justement donc il y
a aussi qui qui se joue ce soir donc on
va avoir les résultats et ce qui se
passe justement au niveau des États qui
qui sont républicains dans les dernières
années déjà une incidence très
importante sur les droits aux États-Unis
on parle bien sûr de le droit à
l'avortement mais aussi le droit des
personnes LGBTQ et des reculs importants
dans les dans les dernières années et
c'est sûr que si ça continue à reculer
comme ça ça va avoir une influence sur
le Canada aussi c'est intéressant parce
que cet été tous les sondages montraient
que les démocrates remontaient la côte
et les électrices entre autres se dit on
va aller voter c'est pas vrai qu'on va
recueillir nos droits vont reculer comme
ça et là l'économie est comme venue
devancé comme sujet de première
préoccupation pour les gens l'inflation
et Christian du four de sorte que les
républicains ont repris l'avance c'est
ça que je vais surveiller moi ce soir
est-ce que la tendance assez importante
qu'on sent en faveur des républicains
depuis quelques semaines est-ce que ça
va se concrétiser dans les jours de ce
soir donc parce que si c'était le cas
bah il y a des conséquences évidemment
que qu'on connaît tous donc Trump je
pense irait ça commence à être assez
probable qu'il y a il peut aussi
peut-être que Joe Biden va être obligé
de laisser la place parce que quand même
des gens qui disent est-ce qu'il va
vraiment être fonctionnel dans un combat
avec Trump pour le reste aussi ce la
frappe c'est que bon moi j'aime pas
beaucoup le catastrophesisme
en politique bon c'est la démocratie
américaine à l'action avec ses gros
dysfonctionnements c'est gros problème
je trouve que des fois nous les
Canadiens ou les Québécois ont su ça de
près parce que comment ne pas suivre de
près mais c'est tellement différent de
notre système c'est fondamentalement
différent de notre système qu'on n'est
pas toujours des bons juges moi je
trouve des fois on peut faire des
erreurs assez importantes mais en tout
cas pas dans votre question c'est est-ce
que les républicains vont apporter notre
marque comme semble-t-il ça va être le
gars ce soir donc réponse à peu près
complète et avec des dépouillement au
cours des prochains jours suite des
choses au PLQ
ça se bouscule pour dire non ça se
bouscule pour dire NON refuse on a fait
un tableau ceux qui ont refusé déjà
Denis Coderre qui était crédité du
meilleur score selon le léger Journal de
Montréal hier à 17% des militants en
libéraux 9 % je crois oui 9 % pour la
population générale alors il n'ira pas
Marwa Riskin n'ira pas Gaétan Barrette
ni repas on s'en doutait Sophie brochute
est non au grand jamais et Karl
Blackburn alors ceux qui restent il y en
a quelques-uns on va vous montrer
qu'est-ce qu'on à quoi on doit
s'attendre dans cette course qui est
dans les faits commencé Émilie
j'espère fondamentalement que les
militants numéraux vont voir ça et et
faire une réflexion sur qu'est-ce qui
devrait être fait d'abord c'est tout à
fait possible pour un parti politique
d'avoir un leader par intérim qui est là
pendant longtemps puis prendre le temps
de faire des réflexions disons plus
existentielle je pense que il y a
beaucoup d'analystes qui qui disent et
je pense avec raison que ce qui se passe
au parti des rôles n'avait rien à voir
ou très peu avoir avec la personnalité
spécifique d'une chef mais beaucoup plus
avoir avec des problèmes structurels de
fond et je pense que si on prend pas le
temps de régler ça et qu'on fait juste
mettre un nouveau visage là dessus les
problèmes de fonds vont rester on peut
pas on va pas s'attendre à nous faire
des résultats très différents donc
peut-être une possibilité en voyant
c'est son âge de dire mais faisons des
choses un peu autrement que de juste se
trouver un nouveau leader puis espérer
que ça va changer de monde je pense
compris que la sauveuse ou le Sauveur
n'existe pas Christian là en tout cas il
y a pas évident
je trouve ça un peu vite un peu
superficiel moi ce que je fais au
libéraux de trouver un bon leader par
intérim comme le dit Émilie de prendre
vraiment leur temps parce que la CAQ
veut devenir rusée tôt ou tard un moment
donné il y a des Québécois qui vont
devenir tannés de logo pizza gagne qu'on
va trouver peut-être à regarder tout ça
puis ils vont regarder du côté des
parties de position quel est le parti
d'opposition qui est le plus susceptible
de gouverner les libéraux dans ce
contexte un avantage c'est un parti de
gouvernement c'est un vieux partition on
le dit souvent enracité moi je crois
enracinement des institutions rappelons
que la pandémie a réveillé un vieux
Québec canadien français d'avant la
Révolution tranquille tout le monde
pensait que c'était mort le PQ est tout
sauf mort mais il faut pas qu'il se
trompe il faut qu'il prenne leur temps
bon ça n'irait pas qu'il se trouve deux
trois temples mais moi je persiste des
signes je pense que le chef ou la chef
est très très important dans la
politique moderne il faut que une vraie
course a été élu il y a pas eu de vraies
courses puis il faut qu'il y a quelqu'un
d'exceptionnel je ne lis pas les
problèmes structurels des libéraux mais
je trouve que de trouver la bonne
personne c'est très important parce que
les Québécois au fond ils vont peut-être
essayer de Québec solidaire puis les
libéraux c'est clair que la personnalité
du chef ou de la chef va faire une
grosse différence il faut que cette
personnalité là ce soit quelques idées
en passant ça n'est jamais ça ne nuit
jamais mais la politique c'est pas juste
un débat d'idées
qui n'est plus le même il faut qu'il se
redéfinisse dans ce nouvel jeu de
politique québécoise José
oui mais le Parti libéral du Québec un
avantage c'est qu'il a existé avant
l'axe fédéraliste souverainiste qui
s'est matérialisé vers la fin des années
60 au début des années 70 le PLQ était
fondé en 1877 donc une existence
politique assez riche merci et de
gouvernance avant la fin des années 60
donc si un parti qui serait normalement
capable de se réadapter à l'absence de
cet axe là justement parce que c'est ce
à quoi on est face maintenant c'est bien
lui et moi je pense que oui il y a des
problèmes structurels aux PLQ qui se
sont installés sous jean-charrell qui se
sont accentués sous Philippe Couillard
et Guetta barrette mais je pense que la
combinaison aussi d'une chef qui s'est
avéré incapable de ne serait-ce que
d'insuffler un nouvel espoir pas de
prendre le pouvoir à personne cette
année à ce qu'elle partie de leur prenne
le pouvoir contre la CAF cette année
mais au moins de commencer cette la
construction là elle y a échoué
lamentablement le résultat de l'élection
est à pire encore que sauf les
brouillard pour quand même le faire et
là maintenant l'avenir est ouvert pour
eux ils peuvent ouvrir les fenêtres moi
je suis d'accord avec mes deux collègues
et beaucoup trop tôt pour la course à la
chefferie et là on a la liste oui on a
la liste classique là écoutez c'est sûr
qu'il y a plusieurs refusés
quelqu'un va dire oui une deuxième
personne va dire oui une troisième
personne va dire oui et c'est la
combinaison de la de de remue-méninges
que le pied doit faire de reconnecter
aussi avec ces militants dans dans la
série des nouveaux et d'avoir quelqu'un
si
d'avoir quelqu'un si possible pour les
diriger qui aurait du tirant ben du
Tirado pardon
ça leur donnerait une chance à la
prochaine élection ou l'autre après mais
on ne sait rien de ce qui va arriver au
parti libérale dans les prochains 4 ans
mais ils ont une chance ils ont je vais
vous montrer une seconde avant de
conclure ce bloc parce que je vous ai
montré celui qui avait dit non il y en a
qui ont pas dit non encore quand même
pour quand même acheter Pierre Moreau a
peut-être montré le sondage on va voir
les noms Pierre Moreau qui était à 5 %
il se taillent réfléchit puis comme
comme vous dites les trois il y a pas le
feu non plus
qui n'a pas dit non Joël lightband on
n'a pas dit non en fait il y a même dit
oui qui sont j'ai un peu comme le il se
sent comme le vilain petit canard au
fédéral dans le Parti libéral du Canada
il veut peut-être avoir une nouvelle vie
etc etc à suivre mais il y a pas de nom
qui bouscule tout le monde et tant mieux
en fait c'est ce que vous dites
[Rires]
tout ce qu'on peut avoir comme Denis
c'est une question en mesure finalement
la notoriété déjà mais écoutez on vient
à peine de passer l'élection ok un mot
sur l'Égypte ce qui se passe la cop27 le
ministre Guilbaud qui représente le
Canada a dit ceci on va écouter un petit
extrait radio
vous savez je pourrais pas faire
le tiers de ce que je fais comme
ministre de l'Environnement si ce
n'était de la pluie du Premier ministre
et aujourd'hui le directeur le bureau
directeur parlementaire du budget Ottawa
a donné des chiffres qui donnent quand
même froid dans le dos le cou de tout ça
pour le Canada en pourcentage du PIB
c'est énorme 2021 c'est 0,8 % du PIB
vous allez dire c'est du chinois c'est
plusieurs milliards et qui et c'est
ascendant jusqu'en 2100 où les
changements climatiques ont un prix il a
dit en Egypte le ministre Christian on a
un plan et on en a pas fait on en a fait
plus que on n'avait jamais fait est-ce
que le Canada a une crédibilité encore
et est-ce que où on s'en va dans tout ça
on sent que sa déclaration c'est pour
faire oublier le fait que le Prunus du
Canada c'est pas déplacé et pas en
Égypte ce qui lui a été reproché
puisqu'il diminue un peu sa crédibilité
moi dans ce dossier là ces temps-ci la
question que je me pose est très simple
je suis à quel point le catastrophisme
l'armistice c'est productif parce que
beaucoup de discours qui sont quand même
très très maximise très alarmiste
catastrophiste le secrétaire général des
Nations unies là il va pas être le dos
de la cuillère est-ce que c'est porteur
est-ce que ça va amener les
gouvernements à plus agir ou il peut
avoir des conséquences négatives une des
conséquences négatives c'est qu'il y a
des radicaux en fait de l'environnement
comment ça se manifester en France il y
a eu des incidents qui ont emmené le
ministre la terreur Gérard dermanet a
parlé des côtes terroristes parce que là
il y a des gens qui disent c'est
tellement grave c'est tellement grave
faut agir faut agir les gouvernements
juste pas donc moi c'est la question que
je me pose personnellement est-ce que
c'est porteur ça cette espèce
d'alarmissement parfois de
catastrophisme ce qui était un jeu
Émilie beaucoup à la cop27 c'est un
mécanisme pour financer les pays du Sud
qui eux doivent faire face aux
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
absolument je vais aller Chypre
récemment par exemple le continent
africain qui est responsable de 4% de
des gaz infections essentiellement qui
est un des contrats sont le plus confort
les plus touchées
là avec des 15 degrés au mois de
novembre mais dans des pays où il fait
déjà beaucoup trop chaud ça mène à des à
une essentiellement des ongles qui sont
en train de devenir inhabitables puis je
pense aussi que lorsqu'on parlait
justement je pense c'est juste la
semaine passée à la question des des
immigrants des réfugiés il va avoir de
plus en plus aussi de réfugiés
climatiques qui vont s'en venir vers le
nord aussi si on fait pas attention à ça
donc c'est tout ça c'est tout ça qui est
en jeu et c'est sûr que ça va avoir un
impact ça l'a déjà un impact en fait sur
la géopolitique mondiale lorsque on
demande par exemple au leader africain
d'appuyer l'Ukraine et de prendre
position sur il y a un mouvement de plus
en plus de refus de suivre un bloc
occidental qui lorsqu'il est le temps de
combattre les changements climatiques et
pas encore là assez pour
est vraiment primordial José conclusion
mais oui mais les gouvernements doivent
donner l'exemple donc c'est sûr que le
Canada
pose quand même un certain nombre de
gestes mais pas suffisamment aussi les
résultats sont pas toujours au
rendez-vous et peut-être qu'on devrait
commencer à parler aussi de l'impact sur
la santé des populations oui c'était
géométrie variable Emilia tout à fait
raison mais quand même même ici il y a
un impact sur la santé en Europe de
l'Ouest le réchauffement l'été les
canicules meurtrières etc il sait pas
seulement l'économie qui qui en prend
pour son rhume c'est aussi la santé des
gens Émilie vous a raison le souligner
on parlait de migrants la semaine
dernière à se panel mais la migration
climatique là on a encore rien vu le
sucre les Christian vous dites qu'il y
en a beaucoup vous avez rien vu là c'est
mais je veux dire le directeur du budget
là c'est près ces prédictions là c'est
même si on atteignait tout nos cibles
faut pas oublier ça là
réchauffement de il faut s'adapter c'est
ce qui essaie de chiffrer et dans les
pays du Sud dis-nous non seulement on
n'a pas pollué mais on a la on a les
conséquences les plus dures en Afrique
surtout où en Afrique Pakistan c'est
terminé c'est terminé merci beaucoup
bonne soirée à très bientôt au revoir au
revoir bonsoir pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI